well well here we are
all right people we're going to try
something a little different
we are going to write the message
no less than a thousand word describing
to me who you think you are
Bueller Bueller Bueller
um he's sick my best friend sisters
boyfriends brothers girlfriend heard
from the sky who knows this kid is going
with the girl who saw bears cats out of
31 flavors last night guess it's pretty
serious
he jeopardizes my ability to effectively
govern this student body it's kind of an
[ __ ] done out of love he gives good
kids bad ideas what would you get you
maniacs like to do fun on an app are you
a virgin she's gotten her boobies oh
well I should say you don't my god are
we gonna be like our parents
when you grow up
your heart tires
I can't believe this they forgot my
birthday
don't mess with the bull young man
you'll get the horns what do you care
what I think
I don't even come
hey what are big brothers for what God's
name is going on in here
what was that ruckus eat my shorts
Ferris Bueller you're my hero
I said it before and I'll say it again
life moves pretty fast you don't stop
and look around once in a while you
could miss it